hi and welcome to episode number 14 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am Franciscan boy and I'm here with my
very very lustrous colleague mark
Mandela hey Mark how are you doing I'm
good thanks how you doing France esque
pretty great very excited about today
we're gonna have you having our first
episode ever about storage storage is a
very exciting topic and very very vast a
lot of things that I was storage it's
true I think you know it's one of those
things that everyone kind of has to do
it um may not necessarily think about it
all that much yeah so yeah we're gonna
have our our colleague Paul Newsome yuh
specialized in storage and he's gonna be
telling us everything we want to know
about it so very excited about that yeah
but before that cool thing of the week
cool thing of the week I particularly
like this one as it plays with
communities and I like Cabrini did a lot
one of our fellow of Googlers John Wayne
parrot he wrote an article recently
called building up as on communities or
opinionated deployment tools and crew
Benitez he he built sort of a he calls
it a proof of concept actually looks
really interesting platform as a service
solution called Knoll on top of
communities and sort of looking at how
you can explore communities to build
some more interesting things it's pretty
cool it sort of sits in that sort of her
broker wish space where you know you can
do a git push and it'll build things and
then put it up on on communities for you
um it's quite cool indeed it has a
really nice demo that that shows it sort
of inaction where he he doesn't get
pushing it and then it sort of builds a
docker file and then sort of takes that
live and builds a new version of it kind
of an absolute App Engine e-type way as
well it's it's really kind of a nice
mixture of different paradigms and it
sort of explores how you can you can say
okay cool we have this great
infrastructure of communities what can
we lay on top of that you know to make
things either either better for my
particular use case you know or just
better overall lady ya know I really
like it I went through the through the
article the chip
things that I prefer the mosques by the
way one of them was the demo itself
which is uh built on a ski nima yeah I'd
never seen that before I was really I
really like that I had never seen that
before for people listening uh it's
basically looks like a video but it's
actually so it looks like screenshot of
a terminal but you can actually select
the text yeah yeah you can see like if
you want to copy the command that hasn't
used it so that that's pretty amazing
and also what I like is the first phrase
of the whole pass which is you should be
building on top of Korean at ease
seriously I realize cinnamon I can
definitely get me yeah I like after that
okay I'm sold he's a good article nah
but seriously it's a very very good
article and I think it's very
interesting especially cuz even like if
you want to build are not on top of no
oil or know it no or i don't know i
actually don't know how to run excellent
no I'm gonna call in oil okay it's like
kind of friend for Christmas you know
okay happy so either if you want to user
or not I think it's quite interesting to
see how you can build higher higher
abstractions yeah of Cooper Nettie's how
all of these simple concepts of pods and
and services and replica controllers
they all match together to allow you to
build really really cool stuff really
yeah so yeah we'll definitely have the
link to to that blog post on our show
notes as as always wonderful so why
don't we have a chat with our friend
Paul let's go for that just do it we are
joined today by yet another of our most
excellent of colleagues a gentleman by
the name of Paul newson is joining us
today to focus about storage in the
cloud Paul how are you doing today I'm
doing well thanks mark thank you so much
for joining us it's my pleasure so um if
people don't know who you are which I
hazard a guess is simply not possible um
do you want to give us a little bit
about yourself and your background and
sort of what you do at Google and that's
sort of fun stuff sure so I'm a
developer advocate as Google as you just
mentioned which means I get to do fun
things like this
with my time developer advocates one of
the titles that we give software
engineers who who work in developer
relations so we get to come out to
conferences and talk to customers and
give presentations and and basically
make people aware the awesome stuff we
have in the Google cloud platform and
hopefully inspire them to use it teach
them how to use it and so I'm very
excited to be here today before before I
was a developer advocate for the cloud
platform I had the privilege of working
on the cloud platform for about three
years I was a software engineer on the
cloud storage team which is how I have
become known as the developer advocate
who seems to know something about
storage and why you've asked me to come
here and talk about it today nice and
yeah actually that's that's the whole
point of the episode we want to know
more about storage and these are were
first episode that were we going to
cover storage specifically and there's
so many options that we don't want to
make it like a deep dive on every single
option because the podcast is half an
hour no half a day so how are you gonna
have to concentrate on okay I have some
data I want to store it what do I do
yeah so I'm going to I'm going to try to
kind of give you a road map or a
decision tree about you know have this
stuff and it kind of looks like this so
what's the best fit for me nice um and
and there's sort of a couple of nodes on
that decision tree first let's talk
about your data which is you know is it
structured or is it unstructured if it
kind of looks like a table you know it
has rows and columns roughly speaking
you're looking at structured data and we
have a number of options for that if
it's just a big bag of bytes and you're
sort of handing it to us and saying
here's a big bag of bytes please store
this for me i'm going to ask for it
later that's unstructured storage so you
know first approximation you can think
of the unstructured storage like images
videos zip files you know there's
probably internal structure to these
objects but as far as the storage
services are concerned it's just a bag
of bytes and we're just going to
faithfully reproduce these bytes in the
same order you gave them to us and the
back to you
so in terms of a and and then kind of
the other dimension which we can sort of
look at the different options you have
are fully managed no ops you know cloud
native storage services versus I want to
run my existing storage infrastructure
which I'm running on my own servers I
just want to run that in the cloud so we
kind of have the lift and shift versus
the cloud native approach so if we're
talking about cloud native unstructured
storage that's kind of the simplest
conversation to have if you are a
developer which if you're listening to
this podcast I'm assuming is the case
you're most likely going to use Google
Cloud storage for that because that's
the that's the the one where your
application is in control of the data
there's there's a conversation to be had
about Google Drive and where that fits
into this and and you know so if your
application you know you're adding
something that kind of looks like a new
app in in alongside other apps that are
being used and we want to interact with
data that's stored in spreadsheets and
docs or maybe your own file format but
it kind of looks and feels a lot like
Docs or sheets does there's a there
there may be a place for Google Drive in
that scenario but I'm going to assume
for the rest of this conversation that
you know it's it's that Google Cloud
storage is going to be your unstructured
option there and that's in terms of the
you know the fully managed fully hosted
no ops you just store the stuff and it's
our problem how to serve it up when it
when it gets when you asked for it later
you know if you're if you're looking for
you know more of a lift and shift
solution you can easily run whatever
your existing solution is on our VMs and
we have persistent disk in a variety of
flavors that that can that can be used
to store that there's a lot more ops
overhead to doing that right because you
need to be aware of you know how is my
data replicated across multiple VMs oh I
don't have a single point of failure if
I'm using something like local SSD there
is if you are using a persistent disk
then you're not going to necessarily
lose the data
if if there's a problem with a
particular vm but you may have an
interruption to being able to serve that
data while you bring a new vm up to 22
attached to that persistent disk so
that's kind of your options for
unstructured data so I have a quick
question about a structure version
structured the way you described it was
kind of like if he if he has columns
eighties structure and he just the bag
of bytes then it's not structured what
about a bag of Jason's yeah that's an
interesting question so easy so it kind
of depends how you're going to use it
and how you want to be able to look up
those those Jason's likes so if you you
know I kind of you Jason as an
interchange format in that for example
when you load when you load when you
send a roll of information to bigquery
to load it into bigquery you give it to
bit crazy and JSON format so you could
arguably say that bigquery is storing
you know a whole bunch of JSON data
because that's how you gave it to
bigquery but really it's not that was
just the interchange format that you use
to hand the data to bigquery so it could
figure out you know which which pieces
of data fit into which columns there are
databases which are kind of native JSON
databases I'm not super familiar with
them so I'm not going to talk about them
and say something incorrect but if you
are super familiar with one of those and
you understand how to run it in a
high-availability way you know again you
can run those types of solutions on
compute engine VMs and you know you have
all the advantages of running in the
cloud but there's a lot more ops
overhead on you because you're the one
who's setting up that software you're
making sure that you have the right OS
patches you know and so on and so on and
so on hmm cool so did you actually
address the question you were asking
yeah yeah absolutely uh so okay so then
we've covered the little bed where
distorted when
the data is not is not structured so you
just as you said we like that expression
the bag of bytes what if I have
something more more structured alright
so if you have something more structured
we have a few we have a few options for
that I'm going to say that with no other
information at my disposal except that
you're saying I've got some structured
data and I'm building an app the go to
answer is going to be cloud datastore
cloud datastore is a structured no
sequel database it scales gracefully in
terms of both performance and cost from
zero bytes up two terabytes and and it
has a very flexible schema you don't
have to define your scam up front this
club datastore is is available as its
own as its own standalone you know
service but it was born as the datastore
solution for App Engine so it's really
really well optimized for these serving
scenarios where you have relatively
small pieces of data that you want to
look up by keys and there's structure
within that data in that you have
individual properties within each of
these rows it gives you some limited
querying functionality and it and it
also has some support for crossroad
transactions which can be very important
for certain applications so with no
additional information I'd say go with
cloud datastore it's probably the answer
you want but the other thing I would you
know put up for your consideration is if
you have if you're working in a context
where you have very deep knowledge of
relational databases and you want a
relational database solution because
that's what you know how to program
that's what your staff knows how to
program or you want to take advantage of
some of those features like relational
integrity and a very structured data
model then you should also look into
cloud sequel which is a fully hosted my
sequel solution the the cloud sequel
solution there are now two generations
of it I would encourage you to look into
the second generation it's not it's not
generally available at the time
we are having this interview but you
should go to our website and see if it's
generally available now it's certainly
available for you it's in beta right now
you can you go you can go play with it
and it is very scalable it can handle a
lot of scenarios for most applications
it's probably going to be sufficiently
scalable it's only if you are expecting
a runaway success and you're going to
need to scale into the the terabytes of
data that you may find that it doesn't
scale you know high enough for your
needs so that's kind of the sequel
versus no sequel node of the tree if you
are you know heavily into relational
databases you love relational databases
we have a hosted service where we handle
the operations and and that that would
be cloud sequel if you are far more
comfortable with the no sequel way of
doing things then cloud datastore would
be your choice so those are kind of the
two go two solutions but there's a third
one third structured solution I should
talk about which is cloud big table
cloud big table is kind of a lower level
no sequel solution it is also a no
sequel solution but we're talking about
really heavy machinery the guidance we
give is that if you're storing less than
a few terabytes of data cloud datastore
is probably the way to go in terms of
when to consider moving to cloud big
table we recommend sort of a wone an
approximate one terabyte minimum of data
before cloud big table is going to be a
cost-effective way to start storing your
data the other the other hurdle to
consider with cloud big table is that
you are using a lower level API whereas
with cloud datastore you have you have a
sequel like language that you can use if
that's something you're familiar with it
also has some higher-level libraries
which you can use to access it like the
NDB library that's available as part of
App Engine with cloud big table you're
using the HBase API which if you're
familiar with it is great and if you
already have a bunch of existing code
which uses it then this is exactly what
you should be looking into however it is
a lower level API
it basically gives you sort of put get
scan semantics not higher there's
there's no cross road transactions
there's no sort of query language or
anything like that it's very much a
low-level put gets can sort of API is
there like particular applications or
particular types of data that would be
like very like that are usually used in
time something like big table like
there's a particular use case that's
always looking for particularly use case
that this would be this would be
pertinent for well the the other
characteristic the big table has which
is really really nice for some scenarios
is extremely low latency single-digit
millisecond latency in the 99th
percentile for reads and writes which is
which is pretty amazing the other thing
that big table gives you the opportunity
to do is mix your what I'd call you're
serving workloads with your analytics
workloads on one database which is often
very difficult to do you know this is uh
this is why you know people have data
warehouses right you have your
operational database which is kind of
your serving database the one that is
that that your web your mobile app or
your website is hitting and and and
getting the most up-to-date data and
then you sort of replicate that into
another analytic system which has a
slightly older view of the data and then
you run your your analytics on that with
with cloud big table the the latency is
low enough you can use it as your
operation as a fantastic operational
database you can also for example just
run a MapReduce or a a data flow
directly against your your big table and
if you provision your big table with
enough resources it can handle both the
analytics workload and the serving
workload simultaneously so if you have a
scenario that looks like that big table
is definitely worth looking into very
nice so we've seen a structure visit
structures so for unstructured we say
that cloud storage
he probably the best solution in general
like the co2 solution for structured
depending on how much you structure it
so you may go with C colon a sequel and
for no sequel we said that if you really
want the real thing and you have a huge
amount of data and you want amazing
performance then you should consider big
table but otherwise datastore should be
the go-to solution for most of the cases
yep and that that's all true cool so
what about uh when you want to run
something slightly different like you're
saying yeah okay so if you have a non
sequel you should go with datastore what
if I'm already running MongoDB or stuff
like that how what good people should do
for those yeah again you can just lift
and shift those into the cloud we've got
these great VMs you can choose the the
vm size that you want you can cluster it
in whatever way you want that your
favorite package you know allows you to
do you can choose to run it on on you
know the hard drive back persistent disk
the SSD back persistent disk or local
SSD depending on how much performance
you want and whether the software
package you're using gives you you know
the resilience to two failures so but
again now you're not talking about a
cloud native no ops fully managed
solution at that point like there's a
lot more responsibility on you to
understand what's going on it's it's
just like running it on your own
machines it's just it happens to be
running on our machines instead we've
talked in the past kind of like
computers a continuum this is almost
like this is pretty much storage as a
continuum yeah is it good yeah I want us
to run everything for you and manage all
that stuff for you or do you want to
just you know create your own persistent
disks and worry about like what the eye
of sauron this particular s at stake
right so there's one other there's one
other structured storage solution we
have which which is definitely worth
talking about and that's bigquery people
a lot of people will approach our
platform and and they'll they'll look in
the storage selection in the storage
section in our in our console and they
won't see bigquery there because it's
hiding under big data where it should be
because it's a really great analytics
tool like that is that is its natural
home
so a lot of people won't think about
using it as a storage medium but it's
actually a fantastic way to store your
data the it costs you the same per byte
to store you know archival data in
bigquery that it would cost you to store
it in cloud storage durable reduced
availability class of storage for
example the price of those two things
those two types of storage is the same
per bike but by storing it in bigquery
you can run a sequel query against it
and you can run massive sequel queries
against it and talking about the
continuum of computing the continuum of
storage here you don't need to say you
don't need to tell us when you run a big
query query oh by the way I'd like you
to dedicate you know 1032 Corps servers
to this query please and I need this
much throughput you just give us your
query you give us your data then you
give us your query and we give you the
answer as fast as we can and we have
these very large clusters that are
already provisioned which are this sort
of massive shared tenant solutions so
that you know when I'm running my query
I get to chew up a huge portion of those
resources and then my queries done in
the next ten seconds someone else's
query is taking up those resources so
you get the the sub minute you know
slices of time on these huge analytics
clusters to answer just the question
you're asking it it's really quite quite
an impressive model and i encourage you
to for particularly for data that is not
on your serving path data that you're
going to primarily use to gain insights
from put it in bigquery and keep it
there then you can always do these
ad-hoc queries against it in the sequel
language that you and your analysts
probably already know and are very
proficient with now somebody might say
but wait I need to run a data flow
against it because I'm doing something
like building a machine learning model
for example which I can't do you know
I've got to run my own custom code and I
can't do that in sequel and there are
some there are some features of bigquery
where you can plug code in but it is far
more structured than what you could do
in something like dataflow so and that's
oh that's okay you can still read all of
your information out of bigquery in your
data flow job or your MapReduce job if
you're using data proc with our with our
connectors so you're not limited to only
using sequel for your analysis so
there's really no reason to not store
your long-term archival analytics data
in bigquery that's where you should be
using it for your data warehouse nice so
okay so I think that now I almost
understand or how are options that we
have for for cloud storage so just to go
over all of them quite quick we made the
distinction between what we're saying is
pretty much managing cloud native and we
still have a bunch of other
possibilities which is like you build it
on top of VMs and you install whatever
you feel like it but for the ones that
we propose as clown natives we have
cloud storage for a structured and then
cloud sequel for sequel datastore for
non-sequel for not sequel a big table
for no sequel that runs incredibly fast
and it's huge and it's huge and then we
also have bigquery which I really had
not think about a storage solution but I
really yeah I can definitely see it
every like it it's interesting actually
you could almost say that bigquery sits
in a weird space between like sequin
windows equal because you can do fun
stuff like query Jason out of it yeah
and and but still have a schema at the
same time if you wanted to think you
have you be Chris kind of an amazing
product actually it's in the middle of
many many many cool tools that we have a
Google cool so is there anything else
that you go like to mention before we
finish with these individually that's a
fine question um let's see well we've
we've touched on the big managed
services i guess i guess the one thing
i'd like to leave is there is a there is
definitely a place for lifting and
shifting existing applications into the
cloud as as a way to get you know a win
out of using the public cloud without
having to do a lot of redevelopment so
so i certainly don't want to discourage
people from doing that however if you're
writing something new i highly highly
highly encourage you
even if it's not what you're currently
familiar with to instead of doing a lift
and shift where you're running your own
thing on your own VMS and you're taking
on all that operational burden I highly
encourage you to see can I can I build
my application on these cloud native
fully managed no ops solutions because
they will allow you to scale very very
high very very easily without hiring you
know an equal number of humans to the
amount to scale to manage the operations
of these things so if you are
approaching the cloud and and doing
something new i highly encourage you to
to preferentially investigate the fully
managed no ops solutions we have to
offer yeah definitely agree with that
especially not only for storage but also
for computing as we're talking like if
you're able to run your code on App
Engine it will pay off very very soon
because you either need to manage
absolutely anything yeah so yeah that's
that's a great piece of advice I think
definitely well thank you very much for
joining us Paul we really appreciate you
taking the time it's been my pleasure
thanks a lot for having me on the show
thank you and I'm sure that we will have
more storage related episodes in the
podcast soon so see you soon all right
thanks a lot guys right right so thank
you very much Paul for these amazing
interview I learned a lot yeah and
definitely yeah actually I know that
this is the first episode of a series of
episodes where Paul's gonna be here
explaining a bunch of stuff on a storage
because there's a lot of things that are
really useful and at the end of the day
where everything we do is you process
data and then you store it somewhere yes
so yeah very important topic uh okay so
let's go for our third section of the
episode the question of the week here so
I think that you got pretty good on
today I think so it's probably a topic
that some people have definitely heard
around the traps the topic was brought
up directly by it to me by gentleman by
the name of Jeff snitzer started talking
about using
java 8 in standard App Engine long
discussed topic of monumental
proportions but what sort of options do
you have if you want to start using Java
rate on App Engine ok so the quick
answer is Java 8 on App Engine doesn't
work yet yeah on classic App Engine what
we call normal my pension but if you
want to you can use it directly on
managed VMs yes so it's something that
works really well and you can get all
the nice things of delight definite now
the thing is that we are actually
working on on having Java 8 supported on
standard app engine but App Engine is a
pretty complex product has a different
run time we change a little like we make
it so it's very safe and scales very
well so you know that that takes
engineering effort it's not an easy
process but I stretch the image but
we're definitely working on it we know
that people want it and I mean we're
developer advocate so we definitely push
me appreciate it yeah we're also pushing
internally to make sure that this
happens and it will happen when well we
can't really say a date yet something
soon I hope very very soon but who knows
but in the meanwhile I've also heard
that there's actually some way of
getting the feel like you're using Java
8 without actually having it yeah so
obviously standard App Engine you're
only limited or you're limited to two
Java 7 but there's a great project out
there called retro lambda so while you
don't get the full features of
everything that comes in job or eight if
you want to use the lambda expressions
but still have it fall back to Java 7
you can totally do that with an app
engine we promote this all probably a
lot more within Android because of the
Java several primers there but no you
can totally use it on App Engine it's
going to make your syntax a whole lot
nicer especially if you've started
playing with lenders a lot more in Java
and a little work down to it'll work
down to Java 7 so if you haven't played
with it within your GAE standard
applications with Java or I reckon give
it a fun go I think it'll be a really
pleasant experience and if you really
want to have actual lamb
this which are real lambdas and closures
and things like that you can also just
migrated to go now just kidding not that
you're biased in this video's any way
shape or form yeah so yeah we'll have a
link to the github repo for Rachel I'm
down the show notes so you can have a
look at it um great so before we finish
as usual where will you be next time
we'll speak together will be so coming
up in a couple of weeks i think it is
yeah there's a couple of weeks launch
hackathon on the twenty-sixth of
februari i will be there I will be a GDC
that is ramping up we're going to have a
great google birth super excited about
that yeah tell if i'm definitely come by
enough cloud spin you're gonna have all
sorts of fun stuff happening at that
event so that's going to be awesome and
then after that i will be at strata nice
i let yourself so by the time this
podcast comes out i will be flying
across the ocean coming back from Dubai
ah so uh there's go for condo by that
will happen yesterday when this podcast
so yeah on Feb return a third there is
no freaking in Dubai and after that yeah
it's gonna be a quite a busy month way
south by southwest GDC here in San
Francisco and there's also droid gun in
San Francisco so and all of those things
of course yeah same week yeah oh yeah
lpg CP next to this is how much stuffs
on I can play AG see you later yeah so
yeah it's gonna be it's gonna be a fun
monthly March yeah looking forward to
April yes very much looking forward to
April my birthday's in March too i
completely forgot that wonderful well
thank you very much for joining us yet
again france ask thank you very much and
as usual if you have any questions any
suggestions any comments yeah we're free
to contact us I don't think we need to
do it today do we need to do it I think
we're okay today I think we're okay
let's do it next next week the next week
wonderful but damn contact us we're very
happy to hear from from all of you
definitely and as usual thank you for
much for being here with me today mark
yeah Thank You Fran set and talk
you next week Phoenix
you